um we're not fighting and my door's
unlocked iced tea and Coco Austin's
seven-year-old daughter Chanel is ready
for the spotlight yeah that's
Coco just shared a clip of her little
girl showing off her acting jobs and
it's impressive
can we not fight anymore please um
the proud momma shared the video to tick
tock on Tuesday explaining that Chanel
filmed starred in and edited the whole
thing by herself
Coco captioned the clip future actor and
director so much passion in this kid and
all that Echoes what Coco told E.T last
month when Ice-T was getting his star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame She's Not
Afraid of the stage definitely she's
left a little talented girl right here
in fact Chanel is already on her way to
stardom last month Coco revealed that
her daughter signed with a talent agency
I wanted to go in the route of not
knowing someone everybody's like oh you
know someone in Hollywood you know a
friend you should you know it's that's
the easy route I really wanted to go buy
the book you know I really wanted her to
audition she auditioned for a
prestigious agency called Zuri and she
got in and we've been uh you know
auditioned for Sesame Street and all
that good stuff so you never know what
might come through so yeah she's been
auditioning for Sesame Street but
Chanel's dream role isn't exactly
kid-friendly
hello
she likes um horror movies right she's
got a really really crazy scream I have
to say she does this like fake scream
inside the car when um Isis driving all
the time and it blows his eardrums out
he's like oh you're gonna do something
with that scream one day girl yes until
then Chanel is bringing all the good
content to tick tock with her famous mom
[Music]
you got me now
it's me
as for Coco she told E.T she loves being
her girl's Mama jar I
have aside for so long because I love
doing her more than me you know I kind
of I kind of stepped up a little bit and
started doing a little bit more social
media but I'm like having more fun with
her so to send you off here's Chanel's
impressive acting chops one more time
can we not fight anymore please um we're
not
Veronica sure you're scared
make me come